Now the second homework assignment here was a signup page.
Here's my signup page, and the idea was you could type in a user name
and a password and an optional email if you want
and then click submit, and it would take you to a welcome page.
Now, if you leave your passwords blank, you get an error message.
If you don't enter both passwords in, it complains that they didn't match.
If you give an invalid name, which in my case I made it be a minimum of 3 characters,
it complains that it's not a valid name, and an email is optional,
but if I type in something that's not a valid email, it complains.
If I type in an email--I'm going to type in some valid stuff and hit submit--
we get to the welcome page.
Okay, let's look at the code for this real quick.
One last thing I did I should show you.
I double check to make sure the user name is valid here too,
so if you put in an invalid name in the URL,
it will automatically redirect you to the signup page.
Okay, let's take a peek at the code.
Here is the portion of the code where we are doing the signup handler.
You can see my URLs down here.
I've got unit2/signup goes to the class signup,
and unit2/welcome goes to the class welcome,
and the signup page, if you just get it, it renders the empty signup form,
which is another template that I'm using.
I'll show you here. This is just HTML.
Now, again, you could have used a big string, and most of you probably did.
Here is my HTML.
You can see it's got a form method post.
I used the table to lay out the form. You don't have to do that.
We didn't grade on the appearance of it.
I just used the table to make my columns line up nice.
The important part was we've got an input type text.
Name is username, and the value,
this is another template variable, and then the error.
Here's another template variable.
This could just as easily be %s in the way that you learned how to do it.
We've got input type password, name password.
Value is blank.
The value is blank here because whenever there's an error,
I don't put the passwords back in the form field.
If there's an error with the passwords, or if there's an error with anything,
we make them retype their passwords.
The password error field.
The verify, input type password, name verify.
That's for verifying the password,
and an error for that one, and then we've got our email,
email optional, type text, name email, value email.
If there's an error with it, we'll leave it in there so they can update it.
And then the error message for that field and input type = submit,
and let's take a peek at the code for this guy.
When you post to here--and what I did is I have a variable called have_error,
and if we make it through this whole function and this is still false,
then we've rendered the success page.
Otherwise, we render the error page.
First I get the parameters.
I get the username, password, verify, email out of the request.
Request.get fetches those parameters.
Then what I do is I run it through these functions that I've written,
validusername, validpassword, and valid_email.
I've defined regular expressions.
I believe we gave these to you for each of these,
so a username is just a through z, 0 through 9.
It basically has to be between 3 and 20 characters.
We provided this to you, and I think we showed you how to use regular expressions as well.
This function is very simple.
If there is a user name, basically if it's not blank and it matches this regular expression, true.
Password is a similar thing, basically any characters between the length 3 and 20.
If there's a password and it matches this regular expression, return true,
and the email, the actual email regular expression to validate an email
is comically long.
It's thousands of characters.
I use a simpler version, which is basically a bunch of characters, an @ sign,
a bunch of characters, a period, and then a bunch of characters.
I find that works pretty well.
If you try to get more complicated than that, there's a good chance you'll
reject what would otherwise be a valid email so I usually let--
if we're going to send emails to people, I let whatever tool I'm using
to send the email--that can break if the email is not valid.
This gets us close enough.
In fact, I think Reddit uses this regular expression still, and it's always worked fine.
I think there's some limits to the length of this, but one more thing.
I make this dictionary called "params," and these are params I'm going to send
back in to rendering.
This would be similar to if you're using the string substitution to draw your HTML.
You're basically going to build up this dictionary of the variables
that you want to substitute in.
I'm always going to send back the username and email
if it's a bad, bad form.
If the username wasn't valid, I add the error_username
to this params dictionary, and I set have_error = true.
If the password isn't valid, here's the password error.
Have_error = true.
If the password is valid and it doesn't equal the verify variable from the request,
we say that the passwords don't match and have_error = true, and then email.
A valid email, if you look, is different from the other ones.
These ones say "return password and."
This one says "return not email or," so what this is saying is
either they don't specify an email or it has to match this regular expression.
Everybody else says they have to give a password
and it has to match the regular expression.
That's how we handle the email is optional case,
and then basically if we have an error,
I just render the signup form again with our error messages,
and if we don't have an error, I redirect to this URL
and put in a username into the URL as a get parameter.
When we handle unit2/welcome, we come to this handler here, welcome.
And we get the username out of the request using request.get,
and then if it's a valid username, render the welcome HTML template,
username = username, or redirect back to the signup page,
and the welcome HTML template is pretty short.
All it is is just basic HTML, and it says "Welcome,"
and then it includes the username, and that's that.
So, that was Homework 2.
I hope you managed to figure everything out.
I hope you now--after seeing my solution with the templates
and your solution with the string substitutions--
are eager to start using these templates on your own.
I'm not going to teach you how to use them specifically,
but there's plenty of documentation on the Google App Engine site,
and I'm sure in the forums there will be lots of activity as well.
And also, we can provide these few lines here and this base class
if you all would find that helpful.
Okay, good job everybody, and on to Unit 3.